hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the first day of the world
blitz championship it's Magnus Carlsen
versus Vladislav artemyev and Magnus
Carlsen is leading the pack once again
ahead of everyone he's in the sole lead
and the vladislav enemy will try and do
something about that now in 2014 Magnus
Carlsen was able to win the World
vultures championship in classical time
format and also in the rapid end bullet
so here he is very close in doing it
again he is the world champion in
classical time format he just won the
world rapid championship and now he is
leading in the world blitz championship
so let's see how he deals with the young
Russian Grandmaster Vladislav artemyev
and we will have a very exciting opening
the groom fell defense we have d4 Knight
to f6 c4 by Magnus we have g6 Knight to
c3 and d5 the groom fold is on the board
seek actress Knight captures and now
efore going into the main line Knight
captures B captures and Bishop to g7
Bishop aziz c-4 by magnus
we have c5 striking in the center and
now comes nice to e2 adding another
defender to the center nice the c6
attacking the center once again and
defending with Bishop to e3 here
Artemyev castles and the the most common
moves you are just castling and rook to
c1 but Magnus includes the H form which
as of late pretty much every game
contains it it's the alpha zero move and
alpha show just how powerful it can be
so h4 and here our team has started
spending some time to decide whether
this was important for the position as
in in 2019 this move has not been played
last time it was played in 2018 and okay
Queen to a5 now putting pressure on the
c3 pawn preparing captures here but
Magnus just castles and interestingly
our rook the c1 and King to f1 or nomu
siro both castles is a new move in this
position with the inclusion of course
wood of h4 so it is as a move 11 that we
have a completely new game so Artemyev
continues to Bishop to d7 and now rook
the b1 as the b7 pawn is no longer
guarded and now well you can defend it
would be six it's it's very difficult to
imagine this Queen getting out the
bishop
slices this way every everything is
protected the Queen's guards this phone
guards this the screen is pretty much
stuck here so Artemyev prefers to bring
it back Quintus e7 and now h5 so seek
after sandy for Magnus recaptures and
the rook a to d8 and now just h6 pushing
the bishop back we read you the position
from the thumbnail and the officer upon
has reached its destination Bishop back
to h8 and now a beautiful move by Magnus
he wants to get the Queen away from the
D file as the rook occupies it all so he
plays Queen to c1 and the d4 point is
still nicely protected by the bishop and
by the night but there are also some
tactics here for example if you move the
knight Bishop captures an f7 wins the
Queen already so here artemyev doesn't
like his position he goes back looked
the c8 which is a shame since he last
month he played at the d8 now he returns
it and well this rook should stay here
guarding the f7 pawn for now so Queen
back to d8 by Magna the to d2 and here
he allows Knight captures on d4 and
opening up an attack towards the bishop
but it's not good for example if Knight
captures Bishop captures and Bishop
captures before recapturing Magnus will
just play rook the c1 and now already
you have a simple recapture Bishop
captures on f7 again is the threat of
winning the Queen so not possible
instead Knights the a5 by artemyev and
now Bishop back to d3 we have b6 and now
the b7 pawn will no longer be a target
and rook beat the c1 now pushing the
Queen back Queen to be 7 and now Bishop
to g5 and again Artemis start started
wasting some time which is you know the
worst thing if you knew in a
three-minute game these 7 ponies under
attack and he doesn't want to play a six
it creates even more dark square
weaknesses and it logs down his Bishop
on d7 pretty much
so he goes rook F to e 8 but now an
Magnus just wins the C file because
after captures that you cannot recapture
with the rook because you lose the 7
points so Queen captures and rook the c1
now this is how Magnus wins the C file
Queen to b7 and now the very important
d5 and if you remember we've covered a
few games where Magnus played against
see partial Agra were MVL went for his
room fault and he always had at least
one night stuck in the center of the
board if you look at here that all of
the squares are covered that the knight
can use to get back into the game
so it's just something you know when
you're you you're a really strong player
and you play the groom field you will
put a knight on the edge of the board
which is you know every beginner knows
this is something you shouldn't do but
you know that's what happens when you're
an elite player you can do stuff like
that so Bishop to e5 artemiev takes this
opportunity to activate his bishop
because going f4 would be too early here
just Bishop to d6 and now you don't have
a way to further expand and your pawns
could now become vulnerable for example
if e5 Bishop to a3 attacks the rook and
also just the d5 point you're going to
win it you cannot play something like
Roxy 3 since Bishop to b4 attacks the
rook and well you will be unable to move
to move it so after Bishop e5 magnet
schools Bishop to f4 he wants to
eliminate it and then push f4 we have
Queens to be a defending by Artemyev and
now Magnus spent some time analyzing the
position but in the end he decided this
was this was best but should capture
screen captures and now f4 we have Queen
to h5 it's probably best to keep an eye
on the d5 pawn and keep the Queen
somewhere close but he instead he goes
Queen to h5 he wants to activate the
bishop with Bishop to g4 Magnus goes
rook the c7 a useful move because once
again it takes away the only squared the
knight could use to get back into the
game while also attacking the bishop on
d7 so Bishop to g4 with a double attack
but now instead of moving the knight
Magnus just creates a threat of his own
Bishop b5 the rook is unguarded so look
back to f8 and now Magnus just plays
rook captures on e7 which is an
important point to grab since it now
creates a past D point which is very
close to Queenie
so Queen captures on h6 finally the
alpha zero point is eliminated and now
Magnus starts pushing his past pawn with
d6 Queen back to h4 and now Knight to d4
we have looked to be eight preparing to
capture the pawn but now just a 5 so as
the knight is no longer a target here
you can
much to do whatever you want the the
pawns are now nicely placed and it's
hard for black to find the move Queen
the g3 is played hoping hoping for some
tricks here but Magnus well there are a
lot of ways you can play this position
like Bishop to eat it's a really really
beautiful move and just goes for the f7
pawn black is helpless to deal with it
Magnus just says okay i'm i'm up in
material queen f2 let's trade Queens and
my pawns will win the game of course
artemiev declines Queen to c3 and now
Magnus just pushes f5 which is well he
did have to calculate if Queen c1 check
were followed by Queen to h6 was
possible but you will not have to block
with your king I mean you will not have
to move your king if 21 check you're
just gonna block with the Bishop to f1
and there's nothing here if G captures a
six now wil will win the game so G
captures an f5 is played Magnus ghost
Knight captures on f5 Bishop captures
and Queen captures on f5 we have Queen
to d4 with Czech and Magnus just blocks
Queen to f2 yeah we had Queen to d5
attacking the the the bishop on b5 and
here well feel free to pause the video
and try to find the quickest way to
victory now while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the only move that really gives you a
big advantage like a huge one so for
those who just want to enjoy the show
you have a passed point you have to push
it to the point being that yes you
cannot capture because a Queen captures
on f7 followed by Queen g7 or h7 mate
and you already have the threat of just
a rook e8 check picking up the rook
because if the rook is captured then you
bring another Queen into the game so
here our team we've played Queen d1
check Magnus just retreated with the
best Bishop to f1 and it was in this
position that the Vladislav artemyev
also known as chuck norris resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here after the rook moves like you could
go look at fate it doesn't really do
anything to prevent this to come with
check but now again any move wins you
can just play rook e8 wins Queen g3
check wins everything is just winning
you can go here now Rocio threatens mate
in one so not not much you can do here
so now after
this Queen to d1 checking Bishop to f1
Artemis resigned and Magnus keeps his
lead and this is the end of day 1 of the
world blitz championship we're gonna
show at least one more game tomorrow
before the start of day 2 so I'm going
to go through all of your hashtag
suggestions to look for the best games
which is usually the one with with the
most hashtag suggestions and we're gonna
show it and also discuss the standings
and what everyone else did in the in the
championship as there are so many games
played and well it's impossible to cover
all of them yeah yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank dolly Buckland and care long for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
world blitz championship for one more
day you know checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and then we are
continuing our next big saga so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day